Tama donkey-chan, open this place It's me,
psycho, grandma Well, it's been a long time, how
are you free?
It was fate, and
I had a hard time too, but I
was worried about my aunt so I desperately searched for my sympathy
.
But it's strange, and what about that past?
I tried to shut myself
up on the 2nd floor, but the shadows on the door were destroyed, and people came in through the windows on the 2nd floor
along the roof.
And even now, I'm still peeking from somewhere in this hole
.
I'm wearing that mask and taking off the clothes I'm wearing
Let's face
it Mmm, you're making an appeal that it's Ginko It's
really weird Do
you live in a place like this?
You don't know anything, do you
?  Gakozu Locker